nous vous parlions hier de ces éleveurs
qui peinent à trouver des repreneurs
pour leur entreprise et bien ils ne sont
pas les seuls cela concerne beaucoup de
secteur d'activité en particulier les
commerces de proximité ou le BTP par
exemple en andréloire on s'attend à ce
que 9000 entreprises soit à reprendre
dans les 10 années à venir dont 75 % on
moins de 5 salariés léa turqué a
rencontré un repreneur qui a réussi son
projet Thierry Nourdin il a racheté les
fibreries de Touren en 2021 une
entreprise spécialisé dans la
fabrication de produits d'emballage à
base de fibre de bois
regardez c'est l'une des dernières
fibreries d'Europe l'entreprise créée en
1938 tourne toujours il y a maintenant
plus de 2 ans tiri s'est lancé dans
l'aventure entrepreneuriale en Touren en
reprenant cette société et j'ai décidé
de m'installer dans une région la mienne
en l'occurrence pour arrêter de me
promener partout en France ce que je
faisais précédemment reprendre une
société c'est de bénéficier de son
histoire de ses positionnements en terme
de produits de ses relations clients et
ça
permet d'aller plus vite voilà une
reprise qui porte ses fruits les
fibreries de Touren sont basé à CEM dans
le nord du département ici on fabrique
des emballages alimentaires à base de
fibre de bois plus précisément de peupli
et de Touren tout se passe sur place
avec une dizaine de salariés dans
l'entreprise investissement total de
depuis avril 2021 plus de 6 million
d'euros on a mis en place un outil de
production qui nous permet de multiplier
par 4 le volume en gardant en étant à
isopérimètre en terme
d'effectif on doit conquérir de nouveaux
marchés c'est la raison pour laquelle on
développe la filière des vins
spiritiritueux l'esprit entrepreneuriat
nous amène à ça voilà il y a pas de
mauvaise décision quand on se lance une
affaire qui continue à se développer la
surface des bâtiments a été multipliée
par 3 en 2 ans chaque année l'entreprise
12 millions de tapis de fibre destinés
au
maréchés